[Aplausos]
[Música]
os hemos contado aquí en un pasado vídeo
rusia lleva años intentando reducir su
dependencia de las economías
occidentales lo ha hecho reduciendo la
financiación exterior acumulando enormes
reservas e impulsando una política de
sustitución de importaciones sin embargo
el resultado no ha sido particularmente
bueno la economía rusa sigue dependiendo
mucho de los suministros extranjeros
particularmente en lo que respecta a la
alta tecnología por eso ahora las
sanciones internacionales que los
aliados han impuesto sobre rusia están
comenzando a castigar duramente la
economía de este país las mejores
estimaciones que estoy viendo salir
ahora mismo sugieren que la economía
rusa va a recortar sea la mitad de lo
que era antes de esta invasión dalit sin
asesor adjunto de seguridad nacional de
los eeuu para que os hagáis una idea en
2021 cerca del 80% de los fabricantes
rusos afirmaban que simple y llanamente
no podían encontrar en rusia todos los
componentes que necesitaban para su
actividad este es el caso del fabricante
de camiones kamaz que acaba de reconocer
una caída de la producción del 40% por
falta de componentes según ha reconocido
la empresa hay 15.000 empleos en riesgo
[Música]
además según un estudio de la escuela
superior de economía de moscú las
importaciones supusieron en 2020 casi el
75 por ciento de todas las ventas de
bienes de consumo no alimentarios pero
ahora las sanciones están cerrando los
mercados internacionales a rusia lo que
puede suponer un golpe muy duro para su
ya maltrecha economía esto es algo que
ha reconocido el propio vladimir putin
nuestra economía necesitará profundos
cambios estructurales en estas nuevas
realidades y no ocultaré esto no serán
fáciles vladimir putin presidente de
rusia ya os podéis hacer una idea de lo
que todo esto supone en realidad si el
propio putin habla de dificultades en un
país donde las cosas oficialmente
siempre salen bien pues bien justo aquí
es donde todas las miradas se han puesto
sobre china
y rescatará al gigante asiático a la
economía rusa hasta qué punto puede
contar moscú con el apoyo de pekín pues
queridos amigos amigas en este vídeo
vamos a ver todos los detalles atentos
pero un momento porque antes de seguir
queremos haceros un apunte importante
este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
masterworks estanflación seguro que no
dejáis de oír esta palabra un peligroso
cóctel entre inflación alta desempleo y
bajo crecimiento económico en españa nos
estamos acercando mucho a tasas de
inflación de dos dígitos sólo en marzo
llegamos al 9,8 por ciento y eeuu
tampoco se queda muy lejos y cómo
podemos proteger nuestros ahorros ante
esta imparable estanflación bueno pues
no hay una respuesta sencilla ni única
pero la diversificación siempre parece
de las opciones más sensatas en cuanto a
protección y como apuntaban
recientemente desde jp morgan en este
proceso de diversificación los activos
alternativos han venido para quedarse y
qué mejor ejemplo de activo alternativo
que el mercado del arte aquí es donde
entra master masterworks permite a
personas de cualquier parte del mundo
acceder a un mercado hasta ahora
inaccesible para el común de los
mortales el arte el proceso funciona así
el equipo de análisis de masterworks
estudia miles de datos para encontrar
obras financieramente atractivas con
potencial de revalorización
luego las compran por importes que van
desde el millón de dólares hasta los 30
millones y las titularizan mandando una
oferta pública a través de la secc por
último conservan la obra entre 3 y 10
años hasta que se vende pero es rentable
el arte contemporáneo bueno pues este
mercado consiguió mejores datos que el
propio s p500 incluyendo dividendos y es
que de 1995 al 2021 se ha apreciado un
nada desdeñable
164 por ciento ojo muy importante nadie
puede predecir el futuro y los
resultados pasados no aseguran
rendimientos futuros si quieres echarle
un vistazo a masterworks por ti mismo te
dejamos un link con el que te puede
saltar la lista de espera aquí abajo en
la descripción y como siempre a la hora
de invertir mucho cuidado
y nada libre de riesgos pero dicho esto
ahora si arranquemos hasta donde llegará
la ayuda de china
[Música]
idilio en oriente
no es ningún secreto durante los últimos
años la rusia de vladimir putin y la
china de xi jinping han fortalecido
mucho su relación tanto en el terreno
político como si hablamos del propio
business el gigante asiático es con
diferencia el mayor socio comercial de
rusia de hecho casi una cuarta parte de
todo lo que compra anuncia desde ropa
hasta televisores procede de la
república popular china
y no sólo se trata de intercambios
comerciales rusia también se ha
convertido en uno de los principales
receptores internacionales de préstamos
de instituciones financieras chinas
concretamente entre los años 2000 y 2017
el oso ruso recibió financiación china
por más de 150 mil millones de dólares
una cooperación que también alcanza el
campo militar tal y como ya os contamos
en el boletín de patrón ahora los dos
países realizan frecuentemente maniobras
conjuntas
quizás por todo esto cuando los dos
líderes coincidieron en pekín el pasado
4 de febrero del 2022 con ocasión de los
juegos olímpicos de invierno declararon
que la amistad entre ambas potencias no
tenía límites una amistad sin límites
de hecho durante ese encuentro apenas
unas pocas semanas antes de que rusia
lanzara su tormenta de fuego sobre
ucrania se firmaron varios acuerdos por
ejemplo china levantó las restricciones
a la importación de trigo ruso y los dos
países acordaron incrementar sus
intercambios energéticos es decir que
durante los próximos 30 años china
comprará más gas y más petróleo ruso
precisamente por este creciente idilio
entre pekín y moscú cuando los aliados
comenzaron a castigar a economía rusa
con sanciones todas las miradas se
volvieron de repente hacia china
un país cuyo gobierno ha rechazado
tajantemente el uso de sanciones
económicas contra rusia desde 2011 eeuu
ha impuesto más de 100 sanciones a rusia
sin embargo han resuelto algún problema
las sanciones de eeuu es el mundo un
lugar mejor gracias a esas sanciones se
resolverá la cuestión de ucrania gracias
a las sanciones de eeuu a rusia se
garantizará acaso mejor la seguridad
europea gracias a las sanciones de eeuu
watson jim portavoz del ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de la república
popular china la pregunta es acudir a
china al rescate de rusia puede china
mitigar el impacto de las sanciones en
la economía rusa se plantearán las
empresas chinas lanzarse a por los
activos y los mercados que están siendo
abandonados por las empresas
occidentales y ojo porque ya se especula
con que algunas empresas como la china
national petroleum corporation la china
petrochemical corporation o la china
minmetals corporation tres gigantes
públicos se están planteando comprar ya
a precio de saldo muchos activos rusos
pero realmente puede china salvar la
economía rusa pues lo cierto es que no
está tan claro que puedan ni que quieran
atentos
[Música]
en cuestión de capacidad
[Aplausos]
la primera pregunta que tenemos que
hacernos es exactamente qué podría hacer
china para apoyar la economía rusa pues
veamos podemos poner sobre la mesa
varias ideas por ejemplo el gobierno
chino podría facilitar las transacciones
comerciales reduciendo aranceles y
trabas burocráticas podría suministrar
los componentes que ahora rusia ya no
puede comprar en occidente o podría
también hacer que sus grandes empresas
públicas invirtieron en compañías o
proyectos en rusia o adelantar el pago
de parte de los 140 mil millones de
dólares que el banco central ruso tiene
en deuda del propio gobierno chino
incluso podrían crear un banco títere
para ayudar a rusia a saltarse algunas
de las sanciones china podría hacer
todas estas cosas pero el problema es
que nada de esto sería suficiente
por un lado rusia tiene una economía
pequeña y poco desarrollada que
básicamente exporta materias primas así
que por mucho que los chinos estuvieran
dispuestos a comprar cosas en rúsia lo
cierto es que no hay mucho margen además
rusia sigue vendiendo de sus materias
primas a occidente pero incluso si eso
cambiara por ejemplo por un embargo
petrolero para poder venderse a las
chinas se necesitarían unas
infraestructuras que hoy por hoy no
existen y que tardarían años en
construirse
[Música]
si las cosas no son tan sencillas como
un simple cambio de cromos por ejemplo
en 2021 china importó de rusia 10 mil
millones de metros cúbicos de gas a
través del nuevo gasoducto de siberia
sabéis cuánto exportó a europa ese mismo
año 175 mil millones de metros cúbicos y
eso por no recordar que en pekín tampoco
van a estar dispuestos a depender
excesivamente de moscú
[Música]
luego por su parte las empresas chinas
tampoco pueden compensar la pérdida de
acceso a productos avanzados que ahora
las sanciones prohíben vender a rusia y
no pueden por tres motivos primero
porque aunque muchas cosas se produzcan
en china eso no quiere decir que se
puedan vender a rusia los productos que
fabrican las empresas occidentales en
china no pueden venderse a rusia segundo
porque tecnológicamente las empresas
locales chinas o no están tan avanzadas
o dependen de suministros de empresas
occidentales suministros que podrían
peligrar para ellos mismos si luego los
productos terminan en rusia
[Música]
ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de los
aviones las sanciones internacionales
prohíben a las empresas occidentales
como airbus o boeing venden aviones
componentes piezas motores o servicios
de ningún tipo a russia cosas que por
supuesto hacen falta para que los
aviones sigan volando y china- o no las
fabrica o ya ha dicho que no se las van
a vender
y tercero porque muchas empresas chinas
tienen miedo al riesgo reputacional que
las pueda terminar perjudicando en
mercados mucho más lucrativos y también
a que se terminen aprobando sanciones
secundarias es decir sanciones a rusia
ya las empresas que trabajen con este
país
[Música]
esto es lo que ha hecho que empresas
como volvo o tick tock que son de
propiedad china hayan suspendido algunas
operaciones en rusia que no estaban
afectadas por las sanciones y
exactamente los mismos motivos explican
por qué dos de los cuatro grandes bancos
estatales de china el banco de china y
el banco industrial y comercial de china
limitaron sus operaciones con rusia en
cuanto comenzó la invasión que es
también lo mismo que ha hecho el banco
asiático de inversión en
infraestructuras por así decirlo el
banco mundial chino que ha suspendido
los préstamos a rusia y bielorrusia
china está tratando de mantener a rusia
a distancia no quieren exponerse
eludiendo las sanciones internacionales
simon harvey jefe de análisis de divisas
de monex europe en esta misma línea
respecto a la inversión en rusia si es
posible que algunas empresas públicas
chinas terminen comprando en rusia
activos a precio de saldo pero no parece
muy probable el miedo a las sanciones al
riesgo reputacional y el hecho de que el
mercado ruso es muy pequeño son cosas
que frenan cualquier desembarco masivo
por ejemplo pensemos en sao mí que tiene
casi el 40% del mercado de smartphones
de rusia sí seguramente se beneficiará
de la salida de empresas como apple pero
difícilmente asumirá el riesgo de
realizar grandes inversiones en un país
que apenas representa el 3 por ciento de
sus ventas globales china nos salvará el
barco que se hunde de la economía rusa
quizás permitirá que flote un poco más y
se hunda un poco más lentamente is war'
fransat economista de la universidad de
cornell es decir que incluso aunque el
gobierno desee jinping quisiera
realmente echarle una mano a rusia es
posible que no tenga la capacidad de
hacerlo a gran escala porque por
supuesto los chinos no quieren perder
por el camino pero es que lo cierto es
que ni siquiera está claro que realmente
quieran salvar a rusia atentos
[Música]
por favor no más problemas
la economía china no atraviesa su mejor
momento en 2022 espera crecer un 55 % su
objetivo más bajo desde 1991 y desde
luego no está nada claro que lo vayan a
conseguir china está actualmente
lidiando con una crisis inmobiliaria una
posible crisis financiera con las
secuelas de la intervención del estado
en el sector tecnológico con la
competencia de nuevos mercados de
producción como vietnam con un congreso
que tiene que reelegir a xi jinping con
una crisis demográfica y para colmo con
el dichoso coronavirus porque si en
chinas siguen enfermando a la gente en
sus casas aumenta la presión en shanghai
una ciudad de 25 millones de habitantes
mientras los cierres por comités y 9
siguen vigentes de locos es decir que
china no está precisamente para tirar
cohetes suficientes quebraderos de
cabeza tiene y al gobierno de xi jinping
como para arriesgarse ahora a sanciones
y problemas de todo tipo por apoyar con
la economía tan pequeña como la rusa
fijaos por ejemplo en este gráfico
[Música]
mientras los capitales están entrando en
la mayor parte de las economías
emergentes están saliendo de china lo
que puede agravar la crisis de este país
es posible que la invasión rusa de
ucrania haya cambiado la percepción de
muchos inversores y que ya no se fían
tanto de china una salida de capitales
que puede verse agravada por la subida
de tipos de la reserva federal
norteamericana porque pues porque cuando
un país como eeuu sube los tipos a
reducirse la brecha de rentabilidad con
las economías emergentes los inversores
prefieren invertir por ejemplo en deuda
de eeuu que en deudas de países con más
riesgo lo que puede hacer peligrar una
buena parte de estas inversiones las
tenencias extranjeras de bonos chinos
superan los 500 mil millones de dólares
en diciembre de 2021 casi un 50 por
ciento más que en 2020 y eso no es todo
para colmo la guerra de ucrania ha
contribuido a incrementar el precio de
la energía las materias primas y los
alimentos
otra castaña más para china una economía
amigos que ahora más que nunca necesita
la inversión extranjera y los mercados
internacionales para sus exportaciones
que eeuu y la unión europea son mucho
muchísimo más importantes para china que
la economía rusa no me creéis pues solo
tienes que echar un vistazo a los
números
en 2021 el comercio entre china y rúsia
fue de unos 147 mil millones de dólares
con eeuu la cifra superó los 825 mil
millones y con la unión europea los 750
mil es decir el comercio con eeuu y la
unión europea fue en 2021 casi 11 veces
mayor que el comercio con rusia y todo
esto por no hablar de países aliados
como japón corea del sur australia que
casi seguro cumplirán con cualquier
sanción internacional
eso sobre el comercio sobre los flujos
de inversión la cosa es aún más
exagerada así que resumiendo china tiene
problemas china necesita a los mercados
de los inversores internacionales y
rusia en la economía mundial importa más
bien poco y aún no hemos terminado
[Música]
un incendio o una oportunidad
tenemos amigos amigas para china la
invasión rusa de ucrania se está
convirtiendo poco a poco en una enorme
[ __ ] los costes de la energía se han
disparado y el miedo de los inversores
ha crecido la guerra está frenando las
rutas ferroviarias que conectan china
con europa vía rusia y para colmo ahora
los vecinos de china están anunciando
incrementos récords de su presupuesto
militar lo que por supuesto no hace
ninguna gracia en pekín shinzo abe el ex
primer ministro de japón se ha mostrado
incluso partidario de llegar a un
acuerdo para que estados unidos
despliegue armas nucleares en el país
del sol naciente así que podríamos decir
que cada día que pasa la invasión de
ucrania hace menos gracia en china sin
embargo momento porque para pekín podría
tener algo bueno fijaos xi jinping instó
a joe biden a trabajar en conjunto por
la paz la guerra no beneficia a nadie si
ahora china puede negociar con eeuu su
neutralidad a cambio de ciertos
beneficios por ejemplo eliminar parte de
los aranceles aprobados por trump
[Música]
de hecho al poco de producirse la
invasión rusa el 18 de marzo del 2022 xi
jinping y joe biden mantuvieron una
cumbre telefónica que mejoró el tono de
las conversaciones y como gesto de buena
voluntad la administración de bailén
acaba de eliminar los aranceles sobre
352 productos chinos y las empresas
chinas cotizadas en eeuu se dispararon
en bolsa ante la esperanza de que las
relaciones entre ambos países se
normalicen así que si es posible que las
empresas chinas compren activos a
precios altos en rusia e incluso que el
gobierno de sim ping haga algún gesto de
cara a la galería pero difícilmente las
cosas irán mucho más allá lo más
probable es que china ni siquiera
intente rescatar a la economía rusa mala
suerte para moscú ahora bien cómo está
rusia preparándose para hacer frente a
las sanciones como espera resistir el
gobierno de vladímir putin al castigo
que los países aliados le están
imponiendo a rusia pues eso queridos
amigos y amigas lo veremos en un próximo
vídeo aquí en visual político así que no
olvides suscribirte al canal si aún no
lo has hecho y por supuesto si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante
es una mano dándole al botón de like y
dejando tus impresiones en los
comentarios un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]